the Oscars is like the final level of
the video game you know what I'm saying
you made it babe
enough I'm
I'm America and now the star I like got
the star and now it's like the Disco
oh I'm so excited I was like my fave
he's here
oh oh
come on
how are you oh my God oh my God yes yes
yes yes yes I love Sherry I love Sherry
we're friends we're friends I'm excited
uh nervous and just curious to see what
this whole thing is about I mean we've
all grown up watching the Oscars and
from the part of world that we come from
uh it's not every day that you wake up
going to the Oscars I am so grateful to
just be here this feels very surreal I
was so nervous coming here I'm just like
I know I feel good I'm like just
chilling and just fangirling over
everyone here I'm probably more nervous
this year than last year
you know of course when you're a nominee
you're like all the anxiety that you've
had for the year uh I think right now I
just want to make sure that I uh
perfectly enunciate the name of the
winner Big Night Oscars how you feeling
are you excited nervous I'm just just
excited yeah because I mean what a fun
night it is this is where we celebrate
you know everybody's hard work and we
can celebrate you know hand flowers over
to people who've just put in this
passionate performance my first time
being live on stage oh amazed I'll be
playing piano for Sofia Carson yes I
heard sings my songs so amazing I'm
happy for her yes I'm happy for you I'm
happy for me too so please your best
piece of advice for someone who's
persevering and feeling kind of
discouraged at this point in their
career that you are unique that you are
that what you have to offer is the only
thing
that's you and that if you try to be
like somebody else you diminish you well
yours keep on working and and love love
for what you do this is a wonderful year
of artists I've met so many wonderful
artists independent filmmakers short
film animation
actors that I feel really brought it the
impact that you're gonna make has it
sunk in it has not and you know I picked
to myself every day but it just doesn't
feel weird I feel like I'm like in a
fever dream right now like it's amazing
I'm happy it's amazing but I'm just like
where am I you know I don't think it's
sunk in for me it is everybody's dream
it is the mecca of Cinema the LA and all
of us are here I just feel it's not out
of our team it's India who's here and we
are walking as Indians and and for India
it's a very big deal because you know we
are getting this opportunity uh first of
all we're very grateful to the academy
for you know giving us this opportunity
to perform Our Song you know to get to
you know represent our country and our
songs on a platform as big as this it
can't get bigger and this truly is the
best feeling what would you say
representation means to you since you're
someone who's so representative in media
as well
um you know I try to represent honesty I
represent me and when people see
themselves in me that always means the
world when they feel like when they see
me they can be them that always means
the world but I think it starts with
like repping yourself what means
everything it means being
um deliberate and intentional about what
we do and try to make sure that we're
serving not only one audience but all
audiences it's the nature of Cinema it's
a quart of Cinema a cinema cannot be
truly real and Universal if it's not
universally represented I feel like I
can see my family and relatives that
work so hard in the Arts and we've
struggled and we've gone through it all
and we've gone through that Journey now
this year I can watch the nominees and
their Journeys so I really enjoy
watching them because I was there it's
really important that everyone gets an
opportunity to share their side of the
story and to share their perspectives
with the world that's why I've started
as well and I believe that women and
young people need to be given the
opportunity to reflect the world as they
see it so I'm especially rooting for the
Young Artists today and women as well uh
and you know Stephanie Shu Michelle your
many others well I'm really really
totally excited for the first time in
years you know this is uh the first time
I've appeared in the Academy Awards in
70 years here it's got to be something
you know this is really when you talk
about the academy this is what it's
really about man like really just uh
being able to celebrate wonderful bodies
of work if our movie has proven anything
at all is that you know it was just a
little review that we did in Simi Valley
and to be here to go into the night with
11 nomination that goes to show that
anything is possible
[Music]
thank you